the invention and inspiration for deep
compositing can be attributed to several
individuals in particular Peter Hillman
he is being recognized tonight for his
work developing the first proprietary
and then commercially available tools
and workflows for deep compositing he
also established an industry standard
file format for deep image data dr.
Hillman went on to build the first
compositor that worked at wetta deep
compositing turns compositing it's a
three-dimensional process the workflow
is based on deep images each pixel
independently stores objects and dip
this allows the combination of unlimited
numbers of elements without the loss of
quality artists can therefore work
independently on separate elements of
the same shot this dramatically
simplifies production visual effects
shots for the ongoing advancement and
development of tool sets for the deep
compositing techniques in a common deep
image file format that allows advancing
compositing workflows the [ __ ] the
Academy presents a technical technical
achievement award to dr. Peter Tillman
please join us accept your thanks to the
Academy into the saitek committee
developing the deep compositing tools
has been a lot of fun because it's been
a massive joint effort with lots of
people involved in different ways both
technically and artistically and that
kind of artistic technical collaboration
is what visual effects and moviemaking
is all about of course but it does mean
I can't even begin to name everyone
involved even though I'm honored to be
here representing them or I would
particularly like to acknowledge the
compositors at wetter digital for their
help not just for their tolerance in the
early days when things were crashing all
the time and had to be bashed into shape
but also for their suggestions and ideas
that continue to drive things forward
without then the deep calm tools
wouldn't be what they are and I wouldn't
have had so much fun so thanks to them
thank you